the hunting community has regularly held
out one place as the gold standard for
trophy hunting a place they say big-game
hunting is honest and killing saves
lives
I set my coordinates for southern
Zimbabwe the same country where Cecil
was shot and killed not long ago
according to a safari club international
study more than 18,000 hunters from
around the world spend upwards of three
hundred and twenty-five million dollars
on hunting in Africa yearly these are
some of the most iconic animals on the
planet so seeing them shot may be
difficult for me and more difficult is
likely to be hanging around the actual
people who chosen to bring tens of
thousands of dollars to kill animals
here and bring them back as trophies
ooby Valley Conservancy is a massive
privately owned area they invited me to
observe a trophy hunt where I would meet
their team to better understand
conservation through the eyes of a
hunter
at boobie Valley trophy hunters have a
menu of animals to choose from the price
for a zebra giraffe hunt is
approximately eight thousand dollars a
cape buffalo hunt runs twenty thousand
dollars a leopard hunt can cost as much
as twenty eight thousand dollars that a
lion hunt costs $100,000 per cat it is
because of this money that outfits like
booby Valley claim they pay back into a
conservation system what are we looking
for
came here primarily for fur cape buffalo
and eelain and kudu mm-hmm what made you
choose those three and I just got
another marine core it's about 33 years
old you saw out of Africa and the big
cape buffalo herds that they had and
look at those so it's been a long
pursuit I mean my god half my life I'm
finally here there's a lot of lines in
this area okay okay so you want to take
a leak or anything like that don't go
wandering off you don't have to warn me
twice way too many you know we put two
send 200 lines any way anybody wants
them had that same who say photonic what
would give him there no takers
but BBC clearly didn't do all they could
to find a home for the Lions they gave
an interview for a British newspaper and
sent out a couple of emails but I can't
conclude their outreach was exhaustive
blondie Latham general manager booby
Valley thinks about conservation in
different terms land how much land do
it's about 3,200 square kilometers so
the size of maybe Rhode Island in the
United States a whole state
that's what
before it was a hunting Conservancy
booby Valley was a cattle ranch and
Wildlife was denied access to the land
branching nearly pushed the endemic
animal populations to the brink until
the Conservancy came in and reintroduced
the native wildlife about ten years into
the Conservancy we had enough animals
that we could take the hunting actually
covered all of the running costs
Americans looking at this and saying you
know what I'm against hunting why should
you be permitted in a world where lions
are diminishing to continue to hunt
lions if we don't hunt line we wouldn't
have an EV line you've got 850,000 acres
dedicated to wildlife one of the highest
lying densities it is funded by hunting
you take away the hunting there is no
alternative way of funding an operation
this size it would have to revert back
to cattle then it will be more
vulnerable for resettlement so does it's
a no brainer
[Music]